[Music]
I'm the one
two out of three with Patrick Swayze yes
two out of three with Patrick's face yes
we have Bjorn Lombard today let me
properly introduce Our Guest he became
internationally known
for his best-selling book and
controversial book The skeptical
environmentalist in 2001. he's the
former director of Danish government's
environmental assessment Institute eai
in Copenhagen
lamborghs that global warming is real
and man-made and will have a serious
impact but innumerous uh about
enumerates about the other disagreements
with scientific consensus in 2009
Business Insider claimed that Lumberg is
one of the 10 most respected global
warming experts
in 2004 he was listed as times 100 most
influential people
he's got a master's degree in political
science and a PhD in political science
which is kind of wild I want to ask
about that as well having said that it's
great to have you on the podcast today
hey it's great to be here Patrick thanks
for coming out yes
obviously you were off camera you were
telling us your travel skills you've
been all over the place but if you don't
mind being you know before we get
started taking a minute or two and share
with the audience a little bit about
your background how you went from who
you were then to all of a sudden data
statistic climate change global warming
and then who you are today yes and and
it's a weird story and no sorry uh but
but you know fundamentally I'm uh I'm
like I think most sort of young people I
was worried about the environment I was
worried about a lot of things I was a
member of Greenpeace not you know not in
a rubber boat but being worried enough
uh had the backpack the badge the poster
on my wall and you know thought the
world was coming to an end seriously uh
literally what what age is this so uh
yeah uh uh Early College okay 18 20.
um so I had that poster I don't know if
you've ever seen it you know it's a it's
supposedly an Indian saying where it
says only when they caught the last fish
and cut down the last tree where they
realized I say can't eat gold
you'll find that real quick okay later
on of course I've realized that's
actually a it's a it's a made-up quote
from a movie in the 70s yes
well my my post didn't look like that
but yes it's the same quote uh you know
the the fundamental Point here is that I
thought like certainly most of my
friends the world was in a really bad
place and getting worse and worse then I
wrote I read uh an interview with an
American Economist called Julian Simon
in Wyatt magazine back in 1998 and he
said
pretty much everything you know about
the environment is wrong things are in
general getting better
and I was like no that's just crap but
he said one thing that really annoyed me
because by then I was actually teaching
statistics in political science
um and I always told my students to go
check the data and he said exactly that
go check the data and so I figured all
right that's a that's a challenge I'm
gonna prove him wrong of course he's
wrong but I'll we'll have fun so I
brought together some of my best
students and you know we bought his book
and we're gonna go through it and
meticulously show how he's wrong in all
kinds of places
turns out that much of what he said was
right you know
you know it's kind of obvious most
places in rich countries the air has
gotten much much cleaner and in London
we have good data back from 1585 and the
London air got worse and worse and worse
over the last 400 years up till about
1890 and since 1890 it's gotten cleaner
and cleaner and cleaner so that today
London air is cleaner than it's ever
been since Medieval Times you
know this and we don't we don't
about this that
partly because we're rich partly because
we decide to clean up London there is
better today than Medieval Times yeah
and that this is true
probably not the same exact dates for
for Florida but Florida air is much much
better in the U.S air is much better
than it was Force four decades ago
because we've cleaned it up for a lot of
different reasons but mostly because
we're rich and we can afford to do so
when you're poor you want to get rich
when you're rich you actually want to
stop coughing so this is not rocket
science but we don't know and that's
incredibly important and it will become
important as we talk about global
warming because fundamentally people
think global warming just like all the
other threats is the end of the world
it's not it's a slight impediment on the
world getting better so global warming
means the world gets better slightly
slower now that's a very different kind
of worry than the world is going to end
is there any statistics of what age
bracket fears global warming the most
you know like is is there a uh you know
gen Z's or gen wise or you know
Millennials or Boomers or gen X's is
there any statistics on who fears it the
most gen Z is top of the list but no I'm
asking like is there actually statistics
so they it used to be that uh that young
people were it more so global warming
age gab younger Americans most worried
70 18 to 34 uh 56 55 and older how about
the ones in between are they confused
like what about the age uh can you go a
little higher I'm just curious to know
what this okay there it is 15 to 34 so
less and less than global warming will
pose a serious threat in your lifetime
well yeah but that's because when you're
it shows that people fear it less yes as
they age than those like 55 and older
they don't even think about it 29 but
the younger audience 82 percent
understanding global warming issues why
is it that you know it's normally
younger students 18 20 22 that fear this
the most I'll give you my perspective
real quick uh I grew up in LA and he
immigrated to La
um and I remember growing up at the smog
in Los Angeles and we were born within
three years of each other and you
probably read about it that the air in
Los Angeles was horrible the joke was I
don't touch I don't um I don't trust air
I can't touch but the smog was so bad
and you can see the pictures from Los
Angeles through the 70s they went to
unleaded fuel and and other things that
happened with power plants San onofre
went online which is an old nuclear
power plant in Southern California and
so I have a perspective in my own
lifetime that I have seen in LA's error
get much better I don't look at this as
oh screw the grandkids I'm I'm out of
here in 40 years so you know I'm not
worried about it I don't look at it that
way I have perspective on Los Angeles
which was a horribly filthy City and now
you take a look yeah and again the
reason why I'm asking this question
because you'll hear stuff like you know
Greta talk about in 12 years we're all
going to be dead and how dare you you
know an AOC gets up 12 years if we don't
do this so much 30 trillion dollars why
does this resonate with kids more than
it does to people who are older
I I think in some sense it's just
because they live longer they have more
likelihood of experiencing the really
bad impacts of of climate change but
probably also because we're uh you know
when you're young certainly I had that
experience you just hear all these scary
stories and you think oh my God the
world is going to end uh if you're a
little older you've heard a lot of other
scary stories I mean if you think back
to the first environment Summit in the
in the UN in 1972 in Stockholm uh the
head of that environment uh conference
told the world
we have just 10 years left in 1972. so
you know we constantly hear this and you
know there's always the next thing
around that's going to destroy us all
and once you've heard a few of them
maybe you've become a little more
skeptical about the next one and you
should look there's a real there are
real problems and certainly it was a
real problem in Los Angeles with the uh
with the air pollution but we fix these
problems and remember we fixed them by
being smart so you know the main thing
that actually fixed the Los Angeles air
pollution was the innovation of the
catalytic converter it was the you know
because most air pollution in Los
Angeles cost by cars it was basically
that every car got its own little uh you
know cleaning facility and unleaded fuel
you know they're they're talking about
now by 2035 a certain percent of cars
and they're sold in California have to
be electric well there was a time where
they said by a certain date all cars
have to be unleaded fuel but unleaded
fuel in the catalytic converter you're
right yeah combine two make a a huge
change unleaded fuel was a fantastic
idea but it didn't actually increase the
air pollution it but it's very very
polluting uh but it but it's not part of
the air pollution it sits on the ground
and it infects everything you uh you eat
and uh the vegetables that kind of thing
but yes absolutely so so yeah so you
said you were saying so the biggest
difference I just sent you if you can
show it a picture of la before in La now
you said the biggest difference was
catalytic converter the catalytic
converter it's a it's a thing they
invented in 1974 and it basically takes
out a lot of the pollution from the
exhaust pipe it cost a couple hundred
dollars so you know it's not free but
it's not a big deal and we put it on we
enforced it and now the air is much much
cleaner and this also tells you how we
fix most problems we don't fix problems
by telling everyone I'm sorry could you
imagine telling most Los Angeles at Los
Angeles is that the word yeah you got
that thing telling uh sorry you can't
drive
you have to walk run or something that's
never going to work right but you can
tell them put on this catalytic
converter and then we fix much of the
problem so instead of what we're also
trying to do now today with global
warming telling everyone I'm sorry could
you be a little poor a little colder a
little warmer a little more
uncomfortable eat a little less and have
a little less of all the fun stuff but
then we'll try and fix global warming
that'll never work you know yesterday it
will work as technology yesterday we had
Charlie Kirk on and one of the things we
were talking about is the conversation
came about the santis and Trump and I
asked the question I said so if DeSantis
goes against Trump who'll win he says no
Trump's going to win I said if you're a
DeSantis do you go in he says absolutely
he says because you have to go in to
learn how to win the fight he says you
know Reagan didn't win the first time
this person didn't want to kind of going
through the process right he made a very
good point so the first time you write a
book called The skeptical
environmentalist 2001. you coming out
you got some data you're confident but
now you're a bullseye your target right
and everybody wants to prove you wrong
which forces you to go and get better at
your arguments you make your argument
stronger what areas at first when you
wrote your first book where were some of
the leaks where you're like okay these
guys do have a good point let me go look
at this a little bit further okay I
didn't think about this one here oh no I
am right in this part because I know the
whole thing when he went back and forth
they wanted to say that your book was an
opinion piece and then I don't know how
many people wrote against 267 people
appealed to say I can't believe you're
doing this and then eventually they'll
let your book Stay you ended up
essentially winning the fact that the
book stayed but what changed from the
first time you wrote that book were some
areas you knew you had to do even more
research in
so it's it's a difficult question
because uh fundamentally I think I think
I came in as a newbie uh I wrote that
yes I I wrote a lot of stuff that I
think actually held up really well uh
but there was a lot of stuff I didn't
know very well uh I think the big
difference is that now I I get a lot
more of the back side of of of all those
stories I think most of the data that I
told already back in 2001 was correct
simply because I wasn't telling you know
I wasn't saying hey I found this this
was what the international organizations
were telling us you know I I've never
disputed you know global warming I think
the U.N climate panel is the right one
to take uh uh that conversation but what
I actually did was read them uh you know
when when you read most of these the
stuff in the in the newspaper like you
just mentioned AOC telling us we only
have 12 years left look this is the
public sort of PR version of the story
what is actually actually the background
is politicians ask the UN climate
penalty IPC
what will it take to stay at below 1.5
degrees Centigrade which is you know
this made up Target uh and you know it's
basically incredibly difficult to do so
the UN came back and said if you want to
do this almost impossible task you have
to do almost impossible stuff you have
to change your entire economy the entire
Global setup in 12 years
that's how the 12 years ended up it's
basically saying if you want to do
something impossible you've got to do it
in 12 years now that's a technically
true statement that the U.N climate
panel never says you should do this
they're simply saying if you're you know
it's a little bit like saying what would
it take to uh to stop all traffic death
you know about 40 000 people dying in
traffic every year in the US what would
it take to stop all of it well one
suggestion would be to set the speed
limit at three miles an hour nobody
would die
but of course there is some enforcement
issues and I think maybe a lot of people
would not feel particularly comfortable
about that but it's true to say if you
want to get rid of 40 000 people dying
every year on the road one solution
could be to set the speed limit three
miles an hour but it's not actually
recommending that nobody would want that
and it doesn't take into account we have
other things that we like as well like
being able to get to you know our family
in in time can I follow up on that these
days I think that there's such a craving
from most people
for just Universal truths like what is
actually the truth don't give me a
narrative don't give me your opinion
whether it's with covid whether it's
with inflation whether it's you know are
we in a recession are we not like
everyone wants to push their narrative I
think what would be helpful is what are
the resounding Universal truths that
everyone can full on agree upon like
forget about your opinion buddy this is
the truth of this matter when it comes
to climate like you've been pretty clear
that climate change is real man some of
it is man-made what is people on the
left the right up down what are the most
universal basic truths that everyone
agrees upon right from there I'm going
to give you first the thing everyone
agrees on then what most people agree on
and then maybe we'll get it yeah amazing
so everyone pretty much everyone agrees
we're emitting CO2 that says main
greenhouse gas because we burn a lot of
fossil fuel CO2 wraps around the world
makes the world a little bit more uh
sort of holding back infrared radiation
so it actually heats up the world a
little bit that's what everybody agrees
on that's the basic sort of greenhouse
effect or what we call Global Warming or
maybe even climate change so CO2 check
not good we're putting out CO2 and that
causes the world to warm up copy that
it's also universally accepted that if
you change the World's temperature that
will have a cost yeah look at uh look at
Miami and look at Boston they're both
pretty you know good cities to live in
they've certainly been adapted you know
lots of Air Conditioning in Miami lots
of heating in Boston both of these
places would be off if the temperature
gets warmer or if it gets colder because
all of the infrastructure all the
buildings have been built to that
particular temperature if it gets warmer
you know Miami will have to put in more
air conditioning and Boston will have to
put in more air conditioning and
likewise if it gets colder you'll need
to have more heating both of them so
it's fundamentally costly when and the
weather or the climate tracks off from
what it used to be that's the main
reason why global warming is a problem
global warming is a problem because we
track off from what our infrastructure
is adjusted to everywhere on the planet
it's not the end of the world you know a
couple of degrees uh temperature change
is not suddenly going to make Miami or
anywhere else unlivable it's just simply
going to present somewhat of a problem
now everybody would agree with the first
part of it but now I'm tracking into
what most climate economists try to
focus on so climatologists all the
natural scientists they look at what
will happen when you put in more CO2 and
how much does the temperature go up but
economists then try to say What's the
total impact of that what are all the
bats and UPS the positives of that
remember as it gets warmer uh we'll also
be able to produce more food we'll have
more growth days many places in the
world because CO2 is also fertilizer
will also have more green stuff will
probably be able to produce more overall
when you add up all of this it's a
negative that's why it's a problem but
you need to add up all of it most
economists will tell you that the impact
of global warming over the century will
be in the order of say four percent of
GDP so it means that by the end of the
century if we do nothing about climate
it'll feel like we're four percent less
well-off than we otherwise would have
been
there's two almost like inflation for
the world it's it's like a a couple one
or two years of recession over the next
80 years which is why most economists
say it's a problem
not the end of the world this is not a
hundred percent remember also at the
same time and this is a little hard to
hold in your head but the the UN
estimate that we'll be much richer by
the end of the century just like you
know from 1900 to 2000 the world got
incredibly much richer uh the U.N and
standard scenario estimate that each
person in the planet will be 450 as rich
as he or she is today that's an
astounding and wonderful achievement
that that means you know especially if
the world's poor will be pulled out of
poverty lots of great things from that
because of global warming we will not be
as rich instead of being 450 as rich as
we are today it'll feel like we're only
434 percent as rich
yes that's a problem no it's not the end
of the world things will be much better
but slightly less much better
that's why I'm arcing and most climate
economists are arguing this is this is
not the end of the world actually most
other things that happen in the 21st
century will probably be much more
important like for instance our pension
problems you know most countries in the
world especially Rich world I'm not
saving enough for old time for people
when they get old and all the other
problems infrastructure how do we deal
with the fact that you know the world is
aging so we have ever fewer young people
supporting ever more old people there
are lots of other challenges for the
world those are probably going to be
much bigger I just learned that term by
the way I've heard of climate scientists
this is new a new term climate Economist
what's the difference between those two
people so the climate scientists are the
ones who've run the computer models they
all natural scientists that they'd be
like physicists sort of thing and they
basically look at all the natural
effects and try to estimate the natural
uh uh uh variables to say if you put an
extra ton of CO2 how much warmer does it
get that's what they ask the climate
Economist will say all right so
temperature goes up by this we take that
from the climate economy sorry from the
climate scientist
how much will that impact our economy
how much worse is that going to make you
who's more important are they both
obviously equally important you need
both but unfortunately we've had very
little conversation so look uh one of
the climate Economist uh his name is uh
William nordhaus he's a professor at
Yale University he's the only climate
Economist to get The Nobel Prize in
2018. so these are important people but
when you talk to most of the climate
conversation it's all natural science
and that's wrong because you need to
actually say how much is this going to
affect us take one thing that's
incredibly important for Florida sea
level rise yeah obviously you know as
temperatures Rise water just like
everything else expands and that means
you get higher sea levels that's also
absolutely uncommon I live in Miami I
see the sea level the streets get
flooded it's insane they've raised the
roads significantly over the last few
years so we absolutely will have a
problem with sea level rise now the
question is is this going to be
unmanageable or not
and the simple answer is no we know how
to do that and a good example is Holland
Holland basically has 40 of its area
below sea level and yet most people live
there fine if you've ever flown into
Amsterdam uh they're one of the fewer
airports in the world I'm sure who on
their website uh proudly point out that
they are the only major airport that was
uh formerly a site of a naval battle uh
but yeah you fly in there there's no
there's no water you don't have to worry
about this and they've fixed the whole
thing so the total cost of all that
Holland has done over the last 50 years
is about 10 billion dollars so yeah it's
not nothing but it's not a big thing for
a rich country over 50 years here's
here's a question for you like for me
the ability to uh uh sell something you
you'll see a lot of gaslighting you'll
see a lot of uh
exaggerating you know why why use this
to ask for the amount of money that they
ask what was the amount they asked in
Paris accord or even aoc's uh proposal I
think aoc's was 30 trillion yeah
probably Paris Accord was around 100
trillion the number is a big number
they're like ridiculously large numbers
and but you did a video and you said the
fact that the Improvement you know it
would only improve the temperature by
what 0.3 degrees I think that that was
the number that you said in in a uh in
an article with the Paris Accord 100
trillion dollars if you're saying
there's more efficient ways to fix this
you'll see reports and they'll say well
here's what we got capacity Factor by
energy source in 2020 you've got nuclear
options geothermal natural gas
hydropower coal wind solar what is the
most efficient way for us to be able to
catalytic converter 200 bucks you were
talking about right that's kind of what
fixed La yes what are some of the things
we individually could do and what are
some of the things the government can do
to help with this so I'm going to
disappoint you right off the bat and say
this is not a problem that individuals
can fix
people love to talk about oh you should
take your car a little less you should
eat a little less so paper straws are
not going to fix climate change no so
these all good things are memorable damn
please yeah feel free to do them and
they're probably good for other things
but don't believe that this is a
question about us you know doing a
little lesson then we've fixed it the
main issue here is that there is about
you know somewhere between four and six
billion people out there the non-rich
people in this world who want to be rich
that's China India Africa and they want
to get out of poverty and yeah you can't
blame them they will want to do that by
producing much more by becoming rich
just like we are and that will emit a
lot more CO2 unless we have a different
technology to take over and that gets
back to the whole point of the catalytic
converter instead of making this about
us feeling guilty right now and we got
to cut in the next three years which
will be fantastically costly lead to a
lot of
Voters saying no uh you know that's if
you remember back in France in 2018 you
had the yellow vest that were basically
revolting because they said I don't want
to pay more for my gas and you will get
these sorts of protests once people
start seeing the incredible price hikes
that those kinds of policies uh will
lead to you will not be able to do it
and even if you do
you will only be able to do that for the
rich countries which is a small fraction
of the total emissions this is about
finding a way that the world can both
become richer and better off in so many
other ways and also cut its emissions
that's not easy so people you know they
the the people can then can do nothing
about it on a day-to-day basis so keep
driving your gas cars keep smoking
cigarettes matter of fact double down on
cigarettes cigars smoke out now you're
slightly scaring my point but yes look
this is not predominantly about what
each one of us do because the only
reason I ask these questions because
you'll hear the argument I'm obviously
being a little bit sarcastic here but
what I'm saying is it's the blame is on
the people you know here's who it is we
cause this this is because of us and it
is catastrophic if we don't fix it you
know it's gonna be the end of the world
and what about you and other okay so
yeah tell everyone do something about it
and I think this is the main point if
you think this is the end of the world
and a lot lot of people have been led to
believe that it's the end of the world
certainly the media uh sort of narrative
of recent oecd survey showed that all
the rich countries uh about 60 of all
people now believe that global warming
is likely or very likely to lead to the
extinction of mankind and that's just
you know that's crazy that's not at all
what the U.N is telling us and it's 4
000 Page Long report this is not the
story it's the media uh story so if you
think global warming is this meteor
hurtling towards Earth that's all you
should be concerned about that's the AOC
point you know if we have 12 years left
and I get why she thinks that I get why
Greta tunberg thinks it you know you've
they've heard constantly and over again
on the media this is the end of the
world if that's true this should be our
only concern that's absolutely correct
but it's not that's not actually what
global warming is global warming is a
problem not the end of the world and
it's one that we can fix very poorly
right now but that we can fix fairly
effectively over a longer term and that
is through Innovation so again you know
if we could come up with the equivalent
of the catalytic converter for climate
change we could fix can you give us some
more examples of catalytic converters
and I'm being serious like what are some
things we've done that whether it's
entrepreneurs military whether it's got
whoever it is what are some things we've
done so if if I had the full example we
had already solved it and I'd be a very
rich man so I'm going to give you
examples but then I want you to be rich
I want to be rich and I want you to be
rich so uh uh fourth generation nuclear
basically prom it's a new technology so
we're third generation right now it
promises to be incredibly safe and
Incredibly cheap now remember that was
what they said about the other three
generations so you know I'm a little
skeptical but let's see it there's a lot
of good arguments it seems reasonable if
that's true
we could basically have incredibly cheap
electricity in the future that would be
entirely CO2 free how cool would that be
so that's one very obvious solution now
remember electricity is only about 20 of
our emissions we can make it more but
it's still not a solution for most of
the emissions but it would be a
fantastic start so that's one Craig
Venter the guy who cracked the human
genome back in 2000 you may remember him
he's he has some crazy ideas and some of
them are fun crazy so one of them is
that he has this plan
to take genetically modified algae put
them out on the ocean surface and let
them grow there they will suck up
sunlight and CO2
and create oil
we could basically grow our own Saudi
Arabia's out on the ocean surface then
we'd Harvest them we could keep our
entire fossil fuel infrastructure and
remember because the oil has just been
grown out on the ocean surface you know
half a year ago it would be CO2 neutral
now the the important point to remember
is this does not work yet it sort of
works in a laboratory position yes
Exon claim algae biofuel breakthrough
we're still not much closer to
commercialized algae biofuels but but so
the the point here again is I'm not
advocating for this I'm saying this is
one of many many ideas those are the
kinds of things that could power
humanity and the rest of the 21st
century so the point is not to come up
and say oh this is the one that's going
to be the winner there are tons of these
ideas out there we just need one of them
to work so my point is we should be
investing a lot more in those
researchers because researchers are
cheap and imagine if we could come up
with one imagine if this Craig Venter uh
Innovation actually could become true
everyone would buy it not just Rich
well-meaning Americans but also the
Chinese the Indians and the Africans so
the whole point here is to say this is
just like we did with the catalytic
converter we're going to solve this with
technology not by moral exhortations is
that the word you know thou shall not
by the way did you ever see that speech
that was given that guy Constantine
Kissin
uh it was it's sort of where they do it
I think in Oxford University and he's a
comedian and he kind of basically went
in on the I sent this to you on slack
Rocky uh he kind of went in on the um
the woke climate change agenda are you
familiar with this I saw it and he
brilliantly just took that down one by
one by one it's on slack this guy did
you ever see this
can we play that it's seven minutes it's
a rational argument
a small minority I accept
because one of the tenets of weaknesses
of course that your feelings matter more
than the truth but I believe in you I
believe there are those of you here who
are work who are open to rational
arguments so let me make one
we are told that your generation cares
more than any other about one issue in
particular and that issues climate
change
we're told that many of you suffer from
climate anxiety
you wish to save the planet and for
tonight and tonight only I will join you
I will join you in worshiping at the
feet of Saint Greta of climate change
let us all accept right here right now
that we are living through a climate
emergency and our stocks of polar bears
are running extremely low
I join you in this view I truly do now
what are we to do about this huge
problem facing Humanity
what can we in Britain do
we can only do one thing you know why
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions which
means that if Britain was to sink into
the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give a [__]
about saving the planet
and that I don't know if we want to
continue watching the video This goes to
your point where
you you talked about China India and
Africa and he added Latin America they
are concerned of poverty that's their
main concern so we have the luxury here
in the United States or in the EU to
things are so good we forget how good we
have it here that we'll move on to
other issues that are so magnified
beyond our daily living that we all
right we're going to Saint Greta of
climate change right whereas people
struggling to put food on the table in
poor countries or countries that have
famines or countries where wealth
inequality is completely exacerbated
their day-to-day living concerns are not
the global climate and that's kind of
what you were saying initially right
yeah yeah and and look we got to realize
that we're not going to fix climate
change again his point is absolutely
right if all of the rich countries were
to vanish tomorrow or basically stop
emitting CO2 just remember how terrible
this would be you would not be able to
move you'd not be able to keep cool down
here in Miami or warm in in Boston uh
half of all food would not be available
there'd be a lot of terrible
consequences but even if you did this
the net impact would be a reduction of
that one degree Fahrenheit by the end of
the century we would be able to measure
it but not very much and certainly not
before mid-century it would have no
impact so we have no sense of how little
we matter what really matters is to
convince all the people who you rightly
point out have more important priorities
like feeding their kids and making sure
they don't die from easily curable
infectious diseases and basically pull
people out of poverty we are not going
to convince most of the world to do this
by being poor we're only going to
convince people to do this if it
actually makes them at least as rich and
preferably even richer who makes who
makes the money Tom with with you know
follow the money concept who makes them
who wants this like who wants this
hundred trillion dollar or 30 trillion
who's going to benefit the most if AOC
Paris Accord if they're successful who
gets this money
okay I may need you to help me here
um I have I have heard and read more
than once that both AOC and Kofi know
that these immense quantities of money
and the things are going to be thrown at
is really a wealth distribution it truly
a tax and it's a wealth distribution
that the ultimate differences that are
in there are well known
and when I look at it I I say to myself
okay
Pat where's the money going and I've
seen and I haven't done this
exhaustively and this is when you back
up I see traditional energy companies
getting billions of dollars in Grants to
go study well
algae biofuel which seems on the surface
to be a very interesting and good thing
but I I kind of see a lot of that
happening but what I don't see is hey
you know what
one half of China is living in poverty
we cannot even fathom because we don't
see it it's the the visuals are
suppressed and they want electricity a
washer dryer and a car and when you
multiply that times billions of people
it's not one percent it's five six seven
percent correct that's really what we're
talking about is the modernization and
mechanization of the large poor
economies results in tremendous amounts
of CO2 now which is also the argument
for Gen 3 Gen 4 nuclear and electric
cars that are recharged by the cleaner
more efficient Nuclear So that you get
out in front of the creation but
because this is what I've seen with with
the money the money's going in Grants
and money's going to think tanks it
actually doesn't end up on the table of
uh to to help make lives better on on a
on a lower CO2 basis in Uganda so so
absolutely it doesn't go to Uganda but I
would actually argue that that the
grants are the kind of things that I'm
also arguing for that's the research but
that's a tiny fraction of where the
money goes the vast majority simply goes
to buy stuff that we already know in
your research you're talking about like
the consensus groups in Australia no I'm
talking about that we you know we should
absolutely be researching the fourth
generation nuclear power plants or the
uh uh the uh uh Next Generation biofuels
those kinds of things because that's
really really cheap that's basically
buying researchers they cost nothing
what we spend most of our money on is
subsidizing existing solar panels
existing wind turbines existing
technology that we know is in effective
but we just put up more of it so you
know back in in 2009 when we had the uh
one of these endless climate Summits in
Copenhagen uh we have the world's
biggest Wind Farm producer vestless you
may know uh and so when everybody in the
world the Senate we're going to save the
planet back then uh and uh on all Metro
stations Vestas had put up posters and
uh you know
advertising everywhere where it said
make a good climate deal now they're
probably nice people and they want to do
that but it's also very clear that they
would make a ton of money from such a
good agreement right because that agrees
because they're going to build wind
farms out of their product it basically
says use a lot of Vestas products so
yeah follow the money there's going to
be a well it's it's not surprising that
there's a lot of money uh when when you
distribute Yeah a hundred trillion
dollars a lot of people are going to get
rich but but I think also politicians
love this for not predominant because
they uh it's it goes to any particular
place but because they get to distribute
the money and because politicians live
off of uh producing fear if you will
they get to say the world is ending but
if you vote for me I can make it stop
kind of thing and that's a incredibly
powerful metaphor I want to show you
this if you can go up to the vitamin
article that was written about new
vaccines analysis that that just came up
of uh uh uh you have the link if you
just go to vitamin.com it'll come up
just go to vitamin.com wrap just go to
vitamin.com it'll come up go to item
there you go it's on the top right
story right there to your right perfect
okay so if you look at this so new Max
analysis reveals 300 000 excess U.S
debts 147 billion dollars in Damages we
are living in one of the most revealing
uh years of our lifetime particularly
when it comes down to Glorious life
savings covid-19 vaccine but just how
life-saving is it or was it time Reveals
All as research continuously points to
the vaccines and Effectiveness
especially how it was initially sold to
Americans recent data keeps exposing its
uh fallacies and fatality according to
researchers behind a new analysis by
human projects a wing of Portugal based
research from Finance Technologies and
the us9 covid-19 vaccines injured 26.6
million people disabled 1.36 million
people and cost 300 000 excess debts the
economic cost of Damages resulted 147
billion dollars in 2022 alone
researchers behind vaccine damage
projects said they ought to estimate the
human costs including that's cause or
haste hastened by the vaccines as well
as the impact of the overall it economy
of each aspect of the vaccine damage so
if you go a little lower this is from
Edward Dowd we had him on a couple weeks
what is a couple months ago months ago
endowed so he shows the numbers at the
top estimated human cost estimated
economic cost injuries 89.9 billion
disabilities 52.2 billion excess death
5.6 billion but go all the way to the
bottom all the way to the bottom all the
way to the bottom all the way to the
right there okay right there on that
tweet right there
Pfizer moderna in 2020 to combine
covid-19 vaccine Revenue in the U.S of
11.5 billion dollars so for every one
dollar they made it cost the U.S economy
13 quite the negative social societal
Roi largest crime scene in history
multiplied this across the globe numbers
now you have to know that this research
is coming from this organization you
have to go test the research you have to
go do your own due diligence on this to
see where it's at but at doubt is also a
data guy he's done very well for himself
and he went from being a financial guy
to wanting to study all the statistics
wrote a book about it and boom everybody
wants to talk about it and read about it
but here's the question I asked this
because
we went down this rabbit hole with covid
and we thought oh my God it's going to
be amazing it's going to be great a New
York Post story came up that said with
the expert covid uh view blown up green
terror must be next okay this just came
up a month ago I'm sure you've seen the
story it is necessary to consider with
the arguments of courageous Skeptics
like Bjorn lomberg
and others who have long documented the
disconnects from reality in the climate
change discourse despite the alarm
predictions of climate catastrophes many
of these forecasts have been
consistently Off the Mark for example at
the 2021 Glasgow U.N climate Summit John
Kerry claimed we have now only nine
years left to stop global warming that's
pathetic to even say something like that
this followed Prince now King Charles
2019 claimed that we had only 18 months
left and AOC claimed the same year that
we had only 12 years left at least she's
more optimistic these predictions
conflict with the 2004 prediction with
the British greens that climate change
would destroy all human Civilization by
2020. thank God we're still around
Additionally the climate refugees
prediction has
been repeatedly overblown in 2005 the
United Nations environment environment
program forecasted that 50 million
climate refugees would be created by
2010 but this massive migration flow
failed to materialize the proposed
Solutions such as Banning gas stoves
mandating Teslas and eating mealworms
are non-sensual nonsensical and cater to
the emotions of Rich progressives rather
than addressing the actual risk of
climate change so this is the part where
the average person is sitting there who
doesn't have all day all night doesn't
get paid to do research they have a
family they have a wife they have kids
they have a husband they have a job they
have responsibilities they have things
they want to do they want to take care
of their health they want to increase
their financial situation in a better
place but they're trying to reason and
say okay Mr expert Mrs expert okay
government you're here to help us every
time you do I'm a little bit worried I'm
paranoid why was it that covet that was
supposed to be so beneficial for us for
us to go do all this stuff with vaccines
now everybody's turning around and not
looking good especially the experts if
that's the case you ask for all this
money why should we trust you with you
know climate change maybe you're using
the same you know method to get money
out of us and use fear tactics to get us
to fall for this crap do you see The
credibility why the same people that
don't trust the covet argument now are
having a hard time saying is this the
next thing oh absolutely uh so Patrick
I'm again I'm the kind of guy that will
read the UN climate panel report and
actually mostly believe that the climate
scientists are doing good work but some
of their uh policy recommendations are
not very good I would probably do the
same with the covet I'm I'm not I should
just say I'm not a covet expert
whatsoever but you know I know a lot of
these people you know fundamentally I I
probably don't I would tend to not agree
with the with the whole idea that
vaccines were a terrible sort of scam
but
it was very clear that we were being
told in the covet conversation that this
is going to be the end of mankind we
need to do drastic things and one of the
DraStic things we did which a lot of
people were already skeptical about when
we did them was to close our schools we
now know that that was a terribly bad
idea in so many different ways so the
World Bank has shown that you know it
basically costs a lot of kids you know a
year or more of their education around
the world and this makes kids everywhere
poor uh the World Bank estimate it will
cost the world about 1.4 trillion
dollars per year starting in 2040
because these kids will now be out in
the employment market and they will be
less productive because they just lost
the year of schooling around the world
this is terrible and we knew back then
what that tells you is we need to have a
less biased conversation we need to have
an a conversation where it's allowed to
say wait a minute is that a good idea
and that was not allowed because we're
so panicked in the covet conversation
and likewise we seem to be so panicked
in the climate conversation that we
often don't ask the same question so I
absolutely agree with you we need to ask
these questions and I I think a lot of
experts seem to just jump on this one
solution know the solution no matter
what the problem is the solution is
always solar panels and wind turbines no
matter what you ask and that's probably
not correct it's a little part of the
solution but it's not a very large part
of it can I can I challenge something
you said respectfully you just said
let's do it unrespected no damn well
with an Arms Reach of you I'll do it
respectfully
um you say let's have a less biased you
know discussion how do you do that when
so many of these scientific things
inevitably become political and
political has policy and policies
usually got two sides of the aisle
regardless of the the country you're in
because in in politics I think we can
agree Boogeyman get created each side
creates the Boogeyman and then they can
control the outcome which leads to
policies and benefactors in the case of
covid kovid was a boogeyman the control
was masking and Civic controls policies
got put in place for Education the
benefactor now we try turned out
billions and billions of dollars went to
pharmaceutical companies and others
that's always where it is how do you
have a less biased discussion on this
this is my question for you my challenge
to you because you yourself have twice
been part of a good good not good
natured but good logical attempts to
create like the Copenhagen consensus the
Australian consensus and both of those
failed how do we have a less biased
conversation on this I should just say
Copenhagen consensus hasn't actually
failed yet at least
okay so should I say that yes they
didn't come to consensus there's an
awful lot of shouting oh God yes so
anyway you're absolutely right and look
I may be a little
um uh Pollyanna yeah well or naive or or
hopeful uh I tend to believe that when
you work with people who disagree with
you a lot it's worthwhile to be polite
and it's worthwhile to try to sort of
you know engage them in in uh in polite
conversation because it also makes all
the people who listen in much more
likely to say oh maybe he has an
argument and and so I I agree with you
that that it is hard to get people
especially you know sort of in the very
religious uh environmental movement to
get them to move but I think and and
that's back to you Patrick your point of
saying you know most most people have
kids to pick up from school you know
they have other and more important
things to do and and and and so in some
sense it's about convincing them that
there is a problem for instance with
climate change but it's not as big as
it's been promoted it's not the end of
the world it's a problem and many of the
solutions are actually quite expensive
and will deliver quite little and having
that conversation and having
respectfully I think can help make it
more likely that many people are going
to say all right I actually I I think
that that makes some sense maybe we
should start looking more for where can
we get the biggest bang for our buck
what can we actually do and that of
course goes back to the whole idea of
saying this is all about research this
is about making sure that we find these
Innovations that'll make the world able
to to do this at an affordable cost
right because you go back to Al Gore he
created the Boogeyman and convenient
truth and you will jump to Pat in less
than 10 seconds here but we just read
here that the Great Barrier Reef the
pictures he showed was a natural life
cycle happening on one side and there's
actually a monstrous Bloom
simultaneously having on the on the
other side and now the Great Barrier
Reef is actually bigger so what what you
know Gore would be accused of not
accused of but proven rather selective
imagery and editing in building that and
then the polar bears have come back and
everything so it people go oh well you
said this about covid you said this
about Inconvenient Truth and you were
wrong and you were wrong and you were
wrong yeah he won an Oscar for that
correct and now we look back in 2006 won
an Oscar for this well let's just say no
opinion we can factually not the best
scientific indicator right but the point
is but to you use if we understand that
I stopped watching the Oscars a long
time ago but the I mean this year the
movie that
anyways I don't even want to get into it
it's very weird what things they do
there but you know to the average person
being an Oscar award-winning documentary
means you kind of know what you're
talking about you know the whole film
created media critic Collective rating
Rotten Tomatoes was 51 and 61 for meta
critic if you can go to the article you
were just shown a minute prior to this
uh Rob which you had on uh you had a
right there says don't forget the
helpless Critters uh greens love to Hype
up remember the vanishing polar bear
Keystone is Al Gore's moral Panic
Masterpiece and inconvenience who turns
out their numbers are up
from Two and a half to five times since
the 60s allegedly dying Coral of the
Great Barrier Reef now holds more than
more Coral than any time since record
keeping began yeah this is where they
lose credibility thus and and they
should uh because they're not telling us
the full story now remember again the
polar bears and I've been pointing this
out for quite a while uh we have more
polar bears than we've had since 1960s
uh we have much more and this is mostly
not anything to do with climate change
but because we stopped shooting polar
bears you know we actually enacted a a
global treaty back in 1976 where we
dramatically reduced the number of polar
bears we shoot which has led happily to
the fact that we now have many many more
polar bears and again one of the points
I try to emphasize is if you actually
cared about polar bears and if you
wanted to protect them even more
shouldn't we be a little concerned about
the fact that we this year and every
year we shoot about 700 polar bears out
of the 26 500 polar bears there are if
you want to do something to help polar
bears instead of you know not driving
tomorrow maybe you should enact not
shooting 700 polar bears again this is
not rocket science and if we can stop
having this very very polarized
conversation we can actually get
somewhere with you know smart simple
policies it's interesting who what
you're talking about the agreement on
the conservation of polar bears came
into effect in uh May 26 of 1974 in an
effort to protect the species through a
coordinated approach by the five polar
bear range States Soviet what is that
Russia Norway Greenland Denmark
and U.S and Canada
700 a year 26 000 and now uh now it's
what no sorry we used to uh shoot about
15 14 1500 and then it went down to 700
guys and remember 700 is is mostly in
Canada because they're uh it's Inuit
that are allowed to catch them so it's
both caught by into it it's also sold as
a trophy uh hunting and a way to bring
in money to the uh local communities can
you can you pull up those three images
that we have about uh nuclear has the
highest capacity Factor if you can zoom
in a little bit when you look at this so
okay nuclear has a highest capacity
Factor at the top with 92 and a half
percent
uh and by the way this is coming from
U.S energy uh Information Administration
so this is not like something that's
from a Blog it's the U.S department of
energy okay so nuclear 92 and a half
geothermal is 74.3 natural gas around 57
hydropower 42 coal 40 win 35 solar 24.9
yet that's all we keep hearing about if
you go to the next one uh the CO2
emissions you you should have uh yeah
that one right there if you could uh um
there you go and then the last one will
be great uh zoom in a little bit so we
can see it all CO2 missions avoided by
the U.S power industry again nuclear and
that's by million metric tons 476 187
174 45 and geothermal
you know can you explain this chart
right there go back to the one you were
on no just go on the one that we were on
explain this chart what does this mean
to the average person
so well I'm not sure it means anything
to the average person but let's take a
step back and say if you have more
nuclear power you use less of everything
else now you use a little bit less of
wind and solar but you also use less of
fossil fuels and it means you end up
emitting less CO2 nuclear simply
replaces CO2 emitting energy so that's
why nuclear has saved more uh CO2 than
any other technology if you have more
wind if you have more Hydro you also
save CO2 but much less and what you have
to remember is it's really hard to keep
a society running with wind and solar
because you know they predictably will
run out you know at night there's no
solar when the wind dies down there's no
wind and we have no sense of how little
batteries we have right now the world
has batteries uh to to cover enough
electricity consumption in the world uh
for one minute and 15 seconds so you
know fun definitely batteries are not in
any time soon going to be able to step
in on this so whenever you use solar or
you win you inevitably have to have some
backup power that both has greater cost
and that also means typically gas so
unless you're a very
fortuitously position where you have
lots of hydros back up you will emit
more CO2 so nuclear is the only
large-scale way that we can cut a large
part of our CO2 emissions from
electricity Tom what are you noticing in
private Equity what direction money is
going to with nuclear are you seeing
like a trend there yeah you're saying if
you take a look at at the minds of
private equity and in Venture Capital
you you have people like Bill Gurley and
others like him that are pointing out
that
um investment in you know Gen 4 nuclear
is not only uh important but it's
critical because gen 3 nuclear has
proven to be safe and matter if I could
look around France France has got a ton
of nuclear and it's not old nukes right
it's it's relatively new
and so that's how they're being powered
but they're looking at it as investment
opportunities and you're not seeing
you're you're not seeing a bunch of
investment in like the next two percent
more efficient solar panel
um and you're seeing full recognition
that it's that oh we could just get
lithium from seawater and I said and
then you take a look at the energy it
takes to get the the other resources it
takes to get the lithium out of the sea
water but you're seeing tremendous
interest in investments in in in new
nuclear power and more importantly
evangelists saying will you please read
the reports and I'm seeing VCS they'll
tweet it they'll connect to a report and
say will you just read this will you
just read this and they're trying to
push you know rather than just yelling
or making documentaries that are fake
they're trying to get people to read the
facts such as we're right here and so
they're smart people are out on the
Forefront but they're being drowned out
by the political people
follow up on the nuclear thing we were
talking about this off camera but we
started nuclear is one of those words
where I mean it's just you say the word
nuclear people are like have a nuclear
meltdown like you that's a that's a
taboo word you hear that I mean we all
know what happened in World War II in uh
Hiroshima Nagasaki and then there's been
disasters we're talking about the Three
Mile Island that they kind of covered up
in Chernobyl and Chernobyl and uh was it
Nagasaki or Fukushima anyway all these
situations you hear nuclear people get
freaked out is it what should we not be
fearful of when it comes to nuclear so
uh if you actually look at how dangerous
different things are uh given how much
kilowatt hours they produce or how much
energy they produce it turns out that
nuclear is one of the safest things ever
uh it's it's it's a little bit like with
airplane crashes uh actually it's
incredibly safe to fly but every time
there is a crash you will hear about it
great analogy so it's it's a a little
bit the same way with you know Chernobyl
obviously was a terrible disaster uh but
you know uh 10 years later the EU the
World Health Organization the
international nuclear commission and
several other organizations went
together and said how many people
actually died from this and they find
that it's much less than 2 000 people
you know remember this is in a world
where Coal fire power which emits lots
and lots of air pollution will routinely
kill about half a million people every
year but it happens all the time and
it's not one single disaster so it
doesn't kills half a million people so
the air pollution from coal fire power
uh so it's basically the fact that you
know you've cleaned up much of this in
the U.S but most places you just belch
out this black smoke especially in poor
countries and it simply blankets the
neighborhoods with uh with dirty air for
West Virginia
I don't know about that but if you go to
New Delhi for instance it's terrible
literally terrible you know it's like
smoking a pack of cigarettes or
something a day now that's also because
they burn a lot of their agricultural
waste and you know it's not just the
coal-fired power plants but we know that
Coal fire power plants make a huge
impact uh and and the point is there's a
lot of deaths from a lot of different
Technologies how hydropower very clearly
also leads to Big breakdowns of you know
dams that kind of thing uh and you know
even even wind power and solar power you
know people will uh drop down from the
from the rooftops where they're
installing them or down from the from
the uh wind turbines they're not nearly
as dangerous so you know they're still
pretty good so are you advocating for
more use of nuclears because I'm simply
saying nuclear is incredibly safe and we
should recognize that just like you
actually reckon most people recognize
airplanes are incredibly safe yeah
although that's not I think that's
important distinction because you know
these days you hear what is going on in
Ukraine Putin drops a nuclear threat
every single day obviously there's a two
you know different examples but just the
the word nuclear people like you know
like the hair raises on their skin right
there it's alarming yes yes and and just
because you share a word you shouldn't
think that that's just but it's the same
word so exactly exactly kind of hard to
distinguish the two so yeah and this is
also why fourth generation nuclear power
because remember third generation
actually had to be actively protected so
on you know if you lose all power that
was what both hadn't Fukushima and and
Chernobyl if you lose all power
basically you can get a real meltdown
what they're saying is that the new uh
fourth generation nuclear is passively
safe that is if you lose all power it
just stops which of course is a better
setup there's a lot of technological
reasons why we didn't do it for the
third one because you would be like well
shouldn't we've done that already but
yeah so the the point here is it's
potentially much safer it's potentially
much cheaper but again I want to see
that before we we say yay let's go I
want to get a reaction from you on this
story of Kamala Harris kamalair's issues
dire climate change warning in Africa
existential threat to the entire planet
okay she said this three days ago I want
to say April 1st
um vice president Kamala Harris visits
panuka Farm in Zambia Zambia and gave
Stern warning about the existential
threat of climate change calling it a
global priority Harris noted that Africa
has won the lowest uh emitters of
greenhouse gases but is planed some of
the highest cost related to climate
change particularly in terms of food
security Harris highlighted the
importance of climate resilient
Agriculture and reducing greenhouse gas
emissions around the world citing food
scarcity has a cause of conflict and
displacement Harris's visit to Africa as
part of the Biden's Administration
efforts to build partnership and bolster
the continent's growth amid the global
rivalry over its resources what's your
thoughts about the story with Kamala
Harris well it's it's you know very
typical of almost all Western
politicians will go down and lecture uh
poor Africans uh on climate change and I
think it tells you two things first of
all she wants to say this is an
existential threat and it goes back to
that whole conversation we had before
that most people who are advocating on
climate will tell you this is the end of
the world and it's obvious because if
you can get people to believe this is
the end of the world you don't think
about the cost so it's a little bit like
with covet if you know if we don't do
all these Draconian things we're all
going to die then you're more willing to
let yourself do that it is not climate
change is a problem not the end of the
world and that should it be helpful if
you actually tell the truth on that the
second bit is much more Sinister I think
because that goes to saying I'm here in
Africa and a lot of people will
typically say you are so vulnerable to
climate change so that makes it the most
important thing we should all cut our
carbon emissions well why are they
vulnerable because they are poor
remember yes yes poor people are most
vulnerable to climate but they're also
most vulnerable to pretty much
everything else they're vulnerable to
not having enough food to not having
good health not having good schooling
all these other things so why not Target
economy why go climate instead of
economy if you actually want to make
poor people less vulnerable also to
climate but presumably also to all these
other things you lift them out of
poverty it's not rocket science and they
know that themselves so what
Uganda and others are actually saying is
we would like to get rich as you are
Miss Kamala Harris right they would
obviously like to be like the US they
would like to have a lot more energy
what are we telling them where's how I'm
no we're saying you cannot start using
fossil fuels I know we're using what 80
90 of our energy from fossil fuels but
no you can't do that
uh so Uganda actually wants to increase
its emissions and have much more energy
that would make them much richer which
is a tiny fraction per capita of what
the US would ever do but the U.S and
almost all other rich countries are
saying no
we are literally telling no you have to
stay in poverty in order to fix climate
change I think that's incredibly
entitled and of course the reason why we
do that is because Camilla Harris and
all other Western politicians know that
they can't tell you or me or other rich
people I'm sorry you have to go you know
sit in the cold and dark and and be poor
that's never going to work but they
don't seem to mind to tell that to poor
countries and that's of course why a lot
of African countries don't like us very
much just to give give you a sense of
proportion the average person in Uganda
has less power
than what in total for industry and
everything then the average Californian
used to heat his or her pool
that's the sort of level we're talking
about they use more on heating their
pools than the average
Ugandan has for everything and this of
course is why they actually think and I
think they have some moral right to say
that we'd like some more so why doesn't
Greta go down to uh Africa and interact
with people who have so little why
doesn't she do that
yeah she knows that that would look bad
but it is it is it is impressing that
she goes to the U.S and to America to
Americans and Europeans and tell them
you gotta cut but not to Chinese and
Indians and Africans because she knows
that would be looking really bad how
naive is Greta but she came to the
became the face of the movement when she
was 12 years old I mean she dropped out
of Middle School to pursue this you know
not exactly an expert she just cared
about the environment respect now I
think she's 18 years old right she may
have single-handedly brought down Andrew
Tate arguably but the you know she's no
expert right I mean she's not the Doogie
Howser of of climate shout out to that
show I know you watched that back in the
day but how now naive is she and
everyone listens to Greta especially on
the woke left but does she actually know
what's really going on is she actually
understanding budgets and rois and
Investments like could she possibly
understand this as much as scientists
what are your thoughts on Greta so I'm
actually going to surprise you a little
and say I I have a lot of respect to for
Greta she basically listens to what
pretty much everyone tells you the world
is ending and she's at least taking the
consequence of that and saying well if
this is really the end of the world
we've got to do much more than all these
adults are saying I I you know I I
respect that a lot she's misinformed but
it's not her fault it's really because
pretty much everyone in the media in the
mainstream media and you know Kamala
Harris as we just heard is telling us
this is an extential threat unless we do
something about it we might all die I I
think it's you know respect that she
took that consequence what we should
take from that is of course not to say
oh she must be an expert she's just you
know regurgitating what she's heard we
should say maybe we shouldn't scare our
young people this much because there's
no justification for scaring this much
it's a problem but it's not the end of
the world and there's a huge difference
one makes you you give up everything and
makes you give up your school uh the
other one is one of the many challenges
we need to fix in the 21st century she's
she's some people would say
a useful idiot is what she is she's
she's good to be used as a pawn to
validate more of their point and connect
with younger kids students and
oftentimes adults are afraid to go after
somebody that's younger because you seem
like you come across as a bully it's a
perfect person to use and abuse
others who have opposing views it's
extremely strategic she's certainly been
used by a lot of people uh and and she
has had that sort of moral Teflon as
they call it you know the she's a kid
how can how dare how dare you how dare
you're criticizing it and if you're if
you're just if you're just watching
peripherally and you see that you're
like oh my God this girl cares so much
but then you see the pictures of like
where she's getting fake arrested in
Germany I believe you have that Rob and
that you believe that there a lot of it
is is grandstanding and showcasing of
course for for clicks and eyeballs yeah
this image right here so what you what
you see is her being arrested and then
what you don't see behind the scenes I'm
sure you can if you keep looking at the
images pops yeah she's actually really
talking to them basically she looks like
she literally like she's not an expert
this this girl unfortunately is being
used and her shelf life is happening you
know what you know what I want to do
something I want to do something can you
do me a favor and play this video I saw
this video
this guy uh I'm gonna send it to you rob
let me know when you see it this is a
video that uh papa papa let me find this
and send this to you too this is
um airdrop this video validates uh
Robert's MacBook Pro is who I'm sending
it to no don't send it that one I'm
gonna send it to Rob's uh iPhone I send
it to both of them Rob at this point
I'll send it to your blackberry I'll
send it to your next tell I swear to God
I'll do whatever you want by the way
shout out to Rob today he's on the ball
second into it no no he's on fire
sometimes he's got you know he doesn't
get his car
he drank the Vault ring he had it yeah
he had the right drink so Rob if you got
it usually drinking whisper in the
morning
it's old school rob you got it
all right so check this out this video
uh Rob you're allowed to use your voice
buddy you're doing sign language watch
this year watch this here you just got
to see this it's phenomenal okay watch
it if you know it don't say anything
time it ruined the Joker stuff just kind
of watch it have you ever seen this or
no that's what I have not seen this can
human beings be programmed watch this go
ahead watch this
despite what you might be thinking
these two circles are not equal I repeat
these two circles are not equal one is
in fact larger than the other which one
do you think what I need you to do is
determine which one that is red or blue
so please raise your hand if you believe
the blue circle is larger than the red
they look exactly the same blue looks
maybe a little bit better all right
please raise your hand if you believe
the red circle is larger than the blue
that's very good now before I said
anything about these two circles what
was your first instinct
equal right because they look equal and
the reason why they look equal is
because in fact they are equal these two
circles are identical
just about every one of you to raise
your hand and say that they're not so
what do we learn that you can be
manipulated like that to believe in
something that goes against your Natural
Instincts just just imagine just imagine
as a child you're taught that the blue
circle is larger than the red if you say
it enough times you convince yourself
that's the truth
if you're told to lie enough times it
becomes part of your reality wow and if
enough people are taught that lie that
the blue circle is larger than the red
well now it becomes part of the culture
and if that culture then passes that
misinformation along to the Next
Generation Well now it becomes tradition
oh my God
what do you think about this when you
see this what's your reaction how much
truth is there with with the credibility
of how they're using this to get people
say no it's real it's real it's real let
me say oh maybe it is real yeah let me
buy into it right that's totally real
we've seen things generationally in the
United States that were started by one
political party that were adopted by
another and then his and now you look
back in history wait that's not the way
it is this political party said this
when it started I can look at history
but we've gone through generations where
it's been appropriated the other way
it's uh it's all over the place this
pretty much describes our educational
system by the way bingo
this is our educational system for the
most I gotta sit there and listen to
this programming of my kids and they're
going to come down and tell Daddy hey
Daddy the red circle is bigger than the
Blue Dilly it's not no it is because my
teacher said so your teacher is also
brainwashed okay uh uh but I don't care
how many times you show me that video
that blue circle
bigger than the red we all know you
think the blue is bigger than the red
but I think they are genuinely equal and
they both have a voice in America and
I'm talking about those two Serbia no
but but there's credibility behind the
fact that all of us fell for this now by
the way none of us are like above this
nobody can be like well let me tell you
because of my IQ score when I went to
men's [__] you're also part of this
we're all victims of this to some point
okay at some point you fell for this
okay if you fell for Russia you're part
of the circle problem if you fell for
the Russia collusion if you fell for the
covet you're also part of the problem
everybody was convinced it's only one
way or the highway there was no need for
debate there was no need for com for
discussion what was that one story you
told about the teacher she came into the
class and she basically said hey guys I
want to tell you kids that if you have
blue eyes you're smarter than anyone
with brown eyes yes and then all the
blue-eyed kids are like yeah we're
smarter than you and then the teacher
came back the next day she goes actually
I had my facts incorrect it's actually
the brown eyed students that are smarter
than the blue and all the brown-eyed
kids and then she came back the third
day and she's like totally kidding you
guys are all completely equal but it's
just sort of proving your point like if
you can fall for a narrative and you
know you're gullible and you don't
question things white people are racist
[__] maybe they're gonna believe they're
racist and I've wasted all my money
giving to the protesters on behalf of
the marginalized red circle because it
was the same size the whole time and
we've been marching in the streets damn
it we're equal yeah how much of the
problem is this Bjorn well I think
there's certainly a part of this uh that
we're that we're easily manipulated on
many of these things because we don't
have a good connection to most people
don't have any good intuition about what
is global warming if you think back uh
on acid rain do you remember acid rain
in the 1980s uh this idea that air
pollution would actually kill off the
forests it was huge in Germany and I'm
more familiar with the Purple Rain
that's prince
in Germany uh a majority of people
actually believe the acid rain would
lead to uh there'd be no forest in
Germany in the year 2000 which of course
was entirely true untrue and we've had
many of these kinds of uh conversations
now all of them have partly they're
partly true
but they are also massively exaggerated
so I would tend to say this is much more
a question of of there being so much
interest in pushing a story because it
makes for policy makers get to save your
uh your life you know we get to save you
uh it means that you get to spend a lot
of money and it means that you get to
control the conversation for a decade or
so so I get why this happens and and and
I think in our sort of excitement of
getting rid of this we shouldn't forget
there are real problems out there but we
should just have a sort of sense of
what's the right level of concern and we
have no good sense in that and I think
Pat brought up a very good point at the
very beginning this conversation about
like where gen Z Falls uh in terms of
where this is on their list of
priorities and this is at the very top
of their list and it's because a of
course you want to care about the planet
like what kind of psychopath doesn't
care about the planet I think we can all
agree we have one planet despite what
Elon Musk is trying to do on Mar I'm not
moving to Mars anytime soon like we all
care about Earth but then also the age
thing is a big thing if you're 14 years
old if you're 16 years old you're 18
even you can't vote you don't have a job
you haven't been to college yet you're
not worried about
prices and home prices and mortgages and
the stock market these are not concerns
of yours but the Earth you can do
something about that you can care you
can actually tangibly do something quote
unquote to help the environment and
that's why this comes the top of their
list so I can completely empathize and
understand why young people treat this
as such high priority but if they're
only hearing one side of the story why
would they ever know otherwise the only
reason they're hearing that is because
that that they're talking about this
because that's what they're hearing
correct and that's what they're being
taught so they're going to school and
the teachers are telling them this the
biggest problem that's the biggest
problem matter of fact I'm going to ask
you Bill what do you think what do you
think is the biggest problem we're
dealing with right now in the world oh
thank you this is what I've been
spending in the last 20 years of
answering it turns out the question is
wrong
so the
to here is the biggest problem in the
world is that we all die
but we don't have you know a good
technology to avoid it so it doesn't
make sense to rank the worst problems
okay it only makes sense to rank what
are the best Solutions so you know you
can't really say what are big problems
because it depends on whether we have
anything to do about it and it turns out
that there are some really really good
solutions to the world's big problem so
you know you mentioned poverty uh we
know how to get people out of poverty by
getting more trade for instance that is
opening up our trade do you remember you
know 20 years ago everybody was very in
favor of free trade then we started
becoming realizing oh wait there's
actually problems with free trade as
well you know the Rust Belt and that
kind of thing that's absolutely true
we still have not we've kind of lost
sight on the fact that trade still helps
many many more than it inconveniences so
you know for rich countries uh for every
dollar that it cost for people like in
the in the in the Rust Belt It generates
benefits for the US of about seven
dollars so yes we need to compensate
them we need to have that conversation
but for poor countries free trade
generates one dollar a problem for every
time it generates ninety five dollars of
net benefits that's incredible this is
you know that's why of course China got
so much richer that's why China Has
Lifted out most of its population now
from poverty this is because of the
power of free trade so that's one of the
many solutions uh do you mind if I give
you a few more go for it I'm listening
good so so we're actually doing I'm
coming out with a book this month on on
what are the 12 smartest things to do so
this was one of the smart things to do
education is obviously a big issue so
education sucks most places in the world
uh it's certainly uh is terrible for
most of the poor people in the and and
the world they go to school we've
managed to do that and everybody is in
school but they have really really poor
education so they learn almost nothing
uh and one of the reasons is that there
is such a big difference between the
best student in the class and the worst
student in the class if you imagine you
put all the 12 year olds together in one
grade obviously some of these kids know
everything the teacher is saying and
more and some of them have no clue
what's going on so the solution to that
is to get more individualized learning
what what they call learning at the
student's own level one way of doing
this is getting kids in front of a
tablet one hour a day
if you do this right the tablet will
have software in the local language that
actually teaches this student and so the
software very quickly figured out oh the
student is really smart so I can Rush
ahead or the student has no clue what's
going on so I'll back up and start doing
this if you do this it'll cost about
thirty dollars per kit per year now
they're not going to get the tablet
they'll share many of them and you know
these poor countries you'll also need to
have solar panels to recharge them at
night and you need a locker to store
them at night so they don't get stolen
that kind of stuff we've calculated all
that and this is done on many many
studies right it'll cost about thirty
dollars per student per year
but it means that each of these kids
over a year will learn what they
normally would have learned on three
years in school they'll simply learn
three times as much now remember it's
still a pretty crappy school so it's
just less crappy now but it means that
they will become much more productive
when they become adults and they will
produce much more it actually turns out
that this benefit delivers about 65
dollars of benefit for every dollar it
costs so again if we do these these
kinds of things we could actually make
the poor part of the world about 600
billion dollars richer every year
by an investment of about 10 billion
dollars
that's just fantastic yeah so the point
here is to say there's a lot of things
we haven't heard of because they're not
sexy if you will but they just happen to
be incredibly effective let me give you
one more and then I'll I have 12 so you
can just say stop I'll give you one more
yeah so tuberculosis is the world's
leading infectious disease killer it's
not covet it was in 2020 and 2021 right
but even 2022 it was not tuberculosis is
a killer that we don't even think about
anymore in the rich World it used to
kill a lot of us tuberculosis over the
last 200 years probably killed about a
billion people so everyone you know
that's not true but a fourth of everyone
you knew in the 1800s died from killed
Doc Holliday we all know that if you if
you watch Wyatt Earp and Young Guns well
there you go yeah and yeah and it was a
terrible disease but then came a
peninsulin and we basically got rid of
it you know we got we knew how to fix it
and it's not a problem in rich countries
it still is a huge problem so it kills
1.4 million people in the poor part of
the world and this is mostly moms and
dads you know so it's middle-aged people
who've just got their own family we've
already educated them and then they die
that's not just a terrible tragedy for
those families but it also means that
there's less productivity in the in the
uh in the nation which goes back to your
initial Point like how do you if you're
trying to not die of tuberculosis you're
like you want me to worry about the
climate and it's 2100 exactly dream on
yeah and so we need to get more
medication this is mainly a problem of
people actually taking one of the
reasons why it's really hard to get
people to take it is you need to take
the medication for four to six months
have you guys ever gotten like a two two
week uh you know uh uh peninsulin cure
and you need yeah I'm looking for a
two-week vacation Bjorn all right sorry
but I can't help you there but you know
it's hard to keep up doing when you when
you get well you know to keep
remembering to take it but these guys
act actually have to take it for four or
six months and that's really hard so you
need apps you need to have sort of games
maybe tuberculosis and Anonymous where
you get together every week and say yes
I took my pills and that kind of so
there's a lot of ways to sort of engage
people in doing it because if they don't
they create multi-resistant tuberculosis
which is much worse and then we need to
find a lot more so we estimate about 10
billion sorry 10 million people get sick
every year but we only treat about six
million out of them and there's the 4
million that both die but also pass on
the tuberculosis to new generations that
then go on and die so if we do this
it'll cost about six billion dollars but
we'll save about a million people every
year it turns out again it's a it
delivers 46 dollars of social good for
every dollar spent so what we're
basically trying to say is there are
these 12 amazing things
in total they will cost 35 billion
dollars per year not trillion dollars
like you know aoc's uh solutions to
climate a very very small amount it will
save 4.2 million lives every year and it
will make the poor part of the world 1.1
trillion dollars richer every year it
will simply deliver an incredible amount
of good at very low cost and that's the
basic point you know so you ask what are
the biggest problems well here are the
best solutions for the world these are
very cheap they're incredibly effective
and you've never heard of them because
they're not fun right they're not the
kind of thing that we talk about with
climate that makes us all anxious and
politicians can get you worried about
they just happen to be incredibly good
Solutions
what do you think about the fact that
big Pharma can only advertise in two
countries us and New Zealand Tom you
know what I'm thinking about with this
here's what I'm thinking about you know
we talked about this briefly a month and
a half ago and may have even been with
Ed Dowd when we talked about this when
it comes down to Solutions
that is about your health you know or
something that has to do with like a you
know covet vaccine shot you know how
much money Pfizer's valuation doubled
during the two years they went from
being a 40 billion dollar company to
being 100 billion Auto Company during
covet what a great profitable thing
covet was for Pfizer Pfizer was probably
sitting there in this you know room
saying this was a great way to increase
the valuation of the company so if
they're sitting there and they're saying
let's think about what else we can do to
take the company from a 100 billion
dollar company to 300 billion dollar
company uh you know with another
pandemic would kind of speed up the
process or nothing
the Mind goes there I I think the part
about having profit
in the area of Health
there's a part about that that's it's a
little bit uh I understand the
Innovation part where you can innovate
to find Solutions like you know the
debate where some people are sending
cure for cancer is already here but they
don't want to have it because if they do
it it would lose so much money you know
the cure for this is such and such here
but they don't want to have it because
if they do it it would be so many of
these cures are around but they're being
kept aside because other companies will
be affected by that cure and profit
margins could go from XYZ to whatever
how much how much do you think the there
are plenty of other cures out there that
we could solve a lot of the issues we
have on Pennies on a dollar but some
companies are suppressing them from
being known in the public because it
could cost them in their valuation of
you know 20 50 or 70 percent
do you know what I'm asking
um I I I don't think so I I think that
that's mostly sort of uh conspiracy
theory uh we know that we have a lot of
incredible uh uh medical breakthroughs
uh that have happened that you know
basically uh these companies made a lot
of money on them at first because they
sell them to the rich world and then
eventually it goes broaden everybody
gets them uh because the patent runs out
and that's what you know has saved uh
countless lives and has made you know
human health much much better what we're
seeing now increasingly is that the
costs go up you know so for instance
these uh uh uh these uh Gene uh
Gene modification tests uh drugs that
are that are specifically uh designed to
alter your genes because you have a gene
malfunction they caused I just saw this
new story they cost what three million
dollars or something uh that's very very
costly that could only work in the very
richest of countries and they may not be
good value for money uh but the The
crucial bit here is the technological
innovation happens in rich countries
where we're willing to pay for them
a lot of the problems are in poor
countries where they can't pay for them
and so my point here is simply to say
there's a lot of things we already know
how to do we just couldn't really be
bothered spending money on it because
we're focused on other things you know
we're focused if you want to put it very
bluntly we're focused on climate change
because it gets all the attention
instead of these very very simple things
you know malaria is another good example
malaria is almost exclusively in
sub-Saharan Africa it didn't used to be
that way so remember uh you know 36 of
the U.S states in the early 20th century
were endemic and malaria I'm sure I
can't remember the 36a but I'm sure
Florida was one of them uh but when you
grow up when you get rich when you start
putting screens in your doors and you
can afford to tackle this it becomes a
lot easier to tackle that's why we
basically eradicate in most you know
rich rich world countries they haven't
in the World they also a little unlucky
they have a much much worse mosquito
that that distributes the do you think
do you think it's okay for Farm big
Pharma to advertise on TV events
sporting events all that you think
that's okay I don't have a good I I
hadn't thought about that I'd come from
a place where we don't so I I haven't
thought yeah but but but why don't you
guys because you do come from a place
that though it's only two places that do
it's us in New Zealand why don't you
guys why don't the other 190 whatever
amount of countries that we have why
don't they advertise that's a good
question they're not allowed oh by the
way I'm not I'm not saying that we have
the answer I'm just saying let's have
the discourse why like what can we
speculate why they don't allow Pharma
companies to advertise in those
countries so I know when I come to the
US I I see all these ads on all kinds of
things that they can do and I'm sort of
like oh I should do that because it'll
make me more safe and then I'm also
starting worrying oh my god do I have
this do I have this disease could this
be you know I I don't know I'm I'm I'm
I'm just freewheeling here but I'm
guessing that a lot of this uh uh you
know leads to some anxiety as well and
it also leads me to vastly overspend
because I'll you know I I know so when I
go to have you ever guys ever gone to
get vaccinated for some thing then they
tell you did you know this bug
and you know you have no idea is this
something that bites one person in
Sweden every year or is this something
we all die from but you feel like maybe
I should get that vaccine you know it's
it's not
advertising on things you have virtually
no sense of is probably not the right
way to you know get information imagine
if they did it for for Boeing and Airbus
uh you know they were advertising do you
really want to get on a Boeing flight
don't you want to go with a more safe
air but you know that can you make these
decisions it's probably nice to have
other people making those decisions
whether we should
certify them as airworthy what do you
think Tom
um
I'm against Pharma advertising and
um I I go back to a case study that was
um
back when I was growing up there were
afternoon soap operas were very popular
in the United States and um when they
would on General Hospital or
um The Young and Restless there are
these very incredibly popular shows that
were like
the most popular shows on television at
the time
and they would invent some random malady
to create a storyline intention
and an amazing amount of let's face it
mostly Housewives who are home watching
these things used to call their doctor
or go to their doctor and say I think
I've got these two symptoms I think I
have well this is because they saw the
General Hospital and so I think there's
a certain psychosomatic effect that you
can have on the populace and I do not
think that a a hyper-medicated populace
is a good thing and I don't I'm not in
favor of Pharma you know advertising for
two reasons one I don't think there's
the societal benefit is there to scare
and induce and then also Pharma has to
get back the cost of their advertising
and the drugs in America are already
expensive Pat and so now if you're
advertising a Super Bowl commercial well
then the Super Bowl commercial cost is
going to be in in that medication and I
think that you know we did very very
well in the rest of the world with
pharmaceutical Representatives educating
doctors at symposiums and then doctors
you know
um you know prescribe them accordingly
as the various fdas of the world in the
various countries or collections of
countries did it so I I I'm against
um uh medical advertising for that
reason uh psychosomatic effect on the
populace and I and it increases not
decreases the cost of the medications at
the end unit because you got to get the
advertising dollars back and you create
this and suddenly you create this
monster where
you're a research organization looking
for the next problem and you're trying
to find you know the next problem on a
grand scale and you do make a good point
that eradicating malaria which is one of
the things that the Gates Foundation I
don't agree with them on everything at
all but the Gates Foundation one of
their Charters was hey what are one of
our beehags big hairy audacious goals to
quote a popular Business book and they
said let's eradicate malaria on a global
basis and it's not that it's still a
problem in sub-Saharan Africa it said
it's down to sub-Saharan Africa and the
progress has been made you're going to
help Elevate the quality of life for
those folks
you know what you guys maybe think about
both of you
so while you're talking I went up there
and I looked up because what you said
you said there's a part of when you look
at you oh my god do I have this am I not
taking this maybe Chris all the suds
right and in time the way you dicks
inside you know you start kind of being
worried about it so I went online have
you guys ever had anybody in your life
that's hypochondria do you have anybody
close to that type of country do you
have anybody you probably don't because
you live in a country that they don't
advertise but you have somebody it's
fortunately not close to me in my
immediate family but there is a member
of the extended family that we don't
need the details it's just close that's
right the name the name please give us
the name phone number
so people listening can go got it I know
what you mean yeah so do you have
somebody in your life that is uh yeah
the hypochondriac's a real thing they
think they're sick they get and they say
it's like so you know crazy you know
what's crazy about them
it's like I'll sit there and I'll listen
to them and I'll be like man dude I
would hate to be you
because you have so many sick did you
know that if you do this did you know
that if you do that did you know what
the weather did you know that this did
you know that did you know don't touch
that don't know oh my goodness what must
you be thinking about all day long but
here's question how did you become this
can you pull up data Rob type the
following increase in hypochondria cases
in America okay increase in hypochondria
cases in America we're jealous because
in your country this doesn't exist
because in your country you're you're
not being advertised left and right at
the end of the world is coming I I see
if you can pull up a chart because the
one I have right now is shown that it's
been an increase and more and more
people are dealing with hypochondria
they're afraid that they're not healthy
they're not good you know they're having
issues you know I don't know if you're
able to find it or not but keep looking
forward while you're looking forward
we'll talk about it you know uh here's
an article here that says anxiety is the
most searched symptom on Google but how
does that happen though like like here's
who we asked a question last week when
we were talking a couple friends who
gets the best out of you right and we
thought about a couple names and then
the follow-up question was I want you to
think about the person that gets the
worst out of you who gets the worst out
of you okay so then the next question
becomes who do you listen to on
television that by the time you're done
you have anxiety
who do you listen to on YouTube or
television by the time you're done
you're like man you know we got this
right so if you watch advertisements on
health like I'll give you an idea you
know
I I almost don't want to I can't tell
the story it's too it's it's it's a
terrible it's a funny story but I can't
tell this story it's a very now you have
I'm telling you guys you have to I mean
yeah I can't you don't have to name your
name she's gonna feel so bad he's gonna
feel so bad but I'll give you one of the
stories I won't tell the swords whole
story but by the way this one 30 years
ago so we had 30 years yeah past the
statue of limitations on the story I'm
gonna tell you the story I won't tell
the other one but I'll tell this one
because this is not as dark as the other
one we had a guy that were playing
basketball one day 13 14 years old
conversational masturbation comes up
okay this is where we're going obviously
nobody here has ever masturbated but
some do okay
you've heard yes statistics right but my
boys are getting to that age so they're
going through a puberty class that we
gotta sign off and all this stuff and
I'm looking at the content of this
puberty class that they got to go
through I'm like dude I can teach it to
you in five minutes as a father I'll
break it down for you how this stuff
works but so we're going through is
playing basketball one of our guys asked
a question because there was a story
that we can school about AIDS okay and
the story was that you know AIDS is
starting to spread
so then one guy asks a question he says
can you get AIDS by masturbating
and so we collectively as a group are
like of course you can get it we're
playing a prank on this guy this poor
guy gets so scared obviously it's a
dirty prank that you know she sometimes
stop the stuff that happens
this guy gets worried he goes to the
doctor he starts panicking for a couple
weeks he asks this mom to go to the
emergency room goes to the doctor asks
his mom to step out of the room and asks
the doctor can I get AIDS from
masturbating and the doc starts laughing
this is what he mean he says no I'm
telling you because they're talking
about in school right now that this can
happen this was a topic of discussion in
the school for about a month
look at Tom's face for a second Tough by
the way as dumb of an example as I'm
giving you right now go back to when you
were a kid and how somebody would say
something to you I had a cut one time
here okay we got into a fight and I got
a cut and the other guy's blood touched
my blood
about the cape you're gonna die because
that guy's sick you know for a week I
was I'm like this is it I'm going around
telling everybody my family mom I love
you
it hasn't been to I love you if
something happens I love you nothing's
happening right so again I'm giving you
very
simple example here as When We Were
Young what we feared because somebody
bullshitted you into thinking you could
die from XYZ because you're doing this
in a young boy's that's a conversation
boys have amongst boys when you go
through this phase right
you think bring that up to 45 years old
and you're sitting and watching a
basketball game ESPN have you been
farting a lot lately there could be a
cause that you have liver cancer and
with this medicine that's out here right
now by this FDA approve of it or not
they're not FDA approved but if you take
this medicine you need to see your
doctor because if you have farted more
than 17 times in a day that may I know
this is a joke but people are sitting
there saying maybe I have liver cancer
because I fart one too many times maybe
I have this there's a part of me that's
convinced based on what both of your
answer was not Based on data there is a
reason why these other countries don't
allow big Pharma to advertise because it
probably increases anxiety how many can
you Rob can you pull up a commercial to
see what percentage of commercials on TV
are about uh uh some drugs or
prescription or brick Farm I'm so
curious to know what percentage is 70
drug drug I was in a low therapeutic
value study finds no I want to know what
percentage of commercials on TV what
percentage of commercials on TV are big
Pharma yeah I just want to know what
we're solving for one out of every ten
commercials
point six billion I hate Big Spenders
big Pharma spent 6.6 billion dollars
on ads last year
6.6 billion find the total ad spend
overall I just want to know what
percentage is Big Pharma that is all I
want to know what percentage is Big
Pharma and that 20 of that is that
high-speed talking at the end of the end
of the end yeah okay there you go I just
found it this include genital rest and
loss of head okay watch what I just
found check this out check this out Tom
pharmaceutical industry
TV advertising spending in the United
States from 2020 it's shown the dollar
amount but it's also shown on this uh
website statista
uh that says in 2020 TV ad spending of
the big Pharma industry counted for 75
of total ad spend what did you Tom did
you hear what I just said wait a minute
what okay okay so let me send this to
you rob go Google this type in what oh
you found it
75 percent
what what do we talk so no wonder people
have hypochondria in America wow no
wonder people are panicking that they're
dying no wonder people are so worried
about everything because of these at 75
of the time
my question a lot of times I'll go I'll
go from this let's just have a very
strong argument in some area right and
I'm a capitalist to the core so I prefer
to talk to Communists and socialist so
I'll have a Sam cedar or a [__] or a cow
or Pac-Man or what was that Vivek um
not Vivek uh uh one the bigger
socialists he's got an interesting name
a communist or Richard Wolff the
professor who's the number one socialist
professor in America according to Forbes
2016-2017 and I'll talk to them and I'll
say ooh there's a leak right there for
your capitalist argument got it oh okay
you see that they have a point there
they have a point here right and you're
kind of trying to strengthen the
argument
75 percent of AD spend is by big Pharma
if you're sitting there you're wondering
why the other 190 something countries
don't allow Pharma to advertise you have
to ask the question why so what would
happen in America if in 2024 moving
forward we took a six-year break big
Pharma not permanent let's just take a
six year break let's see how much
anxiety drops in America
let's see the levels of anxiety drop in
America I'm never going to hear about
this story end of the story I just gave
you about my friend who back in 13 14
years old he thought he was going to get
AIDS from masturbation I'm sure that
story is going to come up quite often
when people ask me questions he's in the
lobby with a rifle pack
this is why you do it in the fall
that's not that you can't get out that
they can't get in exactly right man what
do you think about this stuff what do
you think about why these countries are
not doing it am I just like you know
going crazy right now thinking about why
these other major countries in the world
don't out allow big Pharma to advertise
on their TVs I think we've just
underlined it and you can take a look at
all this let's take a look at all the
high look at the cost of all the the
hypochondriacs uh needless trips so how
much doctor's time would we save how
much you know deductible expenses
fifteen dollars a time and then and the
people that are hourly that are not paid
a salary but then they don't work those
hours because four hours they're not
there because we all know it takes
forever to sit in a waiting room so they
have to take half a day off and then
they gotta pay 20 bucks add all that
stuff up Pat look at all the time and
costs and societal benefit you would get
out if we just could cut
hypochondria in half in America
but and also my guess is that the the
bigger problem is that we're really all
worried about you know have you ever
have you ever read one of those doctor
books you know when or go on net doctor
and see you know what what are different
kind of symptoms
it's very easy to get to feel that you
know there's a lot of things that could
worry you I don't think we need to be
hyper contracts to actually you know get
more worries uh so so it would cut a lot
more anxiety than just for the for the
high so I so high contracts I'd like to
just uh you know because I think
actually we've sort of ended up in a
place where we're talking very much
about the same thing that we worry about
with climate change that we're in some
ways allowing everyone to expand on all
their fears and worries and if you then
confirmed constantly on TV yes you are
going to die yes that next hurricane you
saw is actually the one that's out to
kill you and it's just going to get
worse from here on out we're essentially
allowing if you will Pharma ads and uh
uh
browsing on WebMD for the climate
conversation as well and maybe we should
ask for a little more sensibility so
that people wouldn't be as scared both
on on uh on medical issues and on
climate well climate in pharmaceutical
industry have one thing in common they
had they they use the prospect of
tremendous Doom to get a purchase
decision and so call it what you will
when you line up with a with a uh
saying you know I'm I'm in I'm
supporting all the following elements of
climate change I'm going to do this
you've made a purchase decision you've
been sold you've been marketed to you've
been lobbied and you made a purchase
decision and so now you're now you're
with that with that group with that mob
and that's what the pharmaceutical
industry is doing they're finding pick a
doom get it out there amplify it and
then be the be the solution
yeah I I think accidentally we have
started a conversation on a topic that I
would love for you to do more research
on that's why you came here today I
don't know I got a job and I gotta go
back in a year yeah you you if you could
I would be so curious to know the link
because I tell you you know how
miserable life can be if you have
somebody who has hypochondria you know
how much it hurts the people around you
do you know why because uh the folks who
have hypochondria they they don't know
it and they're not trying to hurt you
they're sincere I don't think they're
playing games because they need
attention I sincerely believe they are
so afraid that the world is coming to an
end with their help that they're dying
that everybody around them constantly
has to hear the message you have no idea
how sick I am right if you only know how
sick I am you don't know how sick I am
shame on you do you know what I'm going
through you know how sick I am and we
have if we don't bow down and say oh my
God you are so sick and you say the
opposite that's why you don't do
research you don't sympathize for people
like the other person I'm like look man
I love you I understand you you know you
may have some things here but where does
that fear come from now we know thanks
to Big Pharma 75 of ads spent is these
guys by the way if you look it up it
says the U.S consumer drug advertising
boom on television began in 1997 when
the FDA relaxed its guidelines relating
to broadcast media
relating to broadcast media why type in
1997 FDA
uh uh broadcast media
FDA broadcast media can you click on and
see what stories comes up
Consumer Directed broadcasting in 1997
that's the one right there docket number
FDA advertisement consumer director
broadcasting let's see who's on this
bill zoom in a little bit I'm actually
really curious at this point now I have
to go research this here we go freaking
a additional copies of this documentary
okay Officer okay well we're not going
to do it right now but I have to go take
a look at this but to see what was the
reasoning behind it who pushed us okay
the background introduction the Scottish
and the assistant sponsors who are
interested in advertising their
prescription human and animal drug
including biological products for humans
directly to Consumer through broadcast
media such as television radio telephone
Communication System background the FDA
requires manufacturers Packers and
Distributors who advertise prescription
human and animal drugs including
biological products for humans disclose
an advertisement certain information
about the okay that's fine if you
disclose you still scared the crap out
of a bunch of Boomers exactly okay this
prescription drug ones on the
distinguish between them anyways
um
I want to know why the other guys don't
do it so Patrick I've I've heard your
request for me to link into this uh but
if I could just say because I have spent
the last 20 years on on figuring out how
people worry about climate change uh so
let me just you know take it back to
saying sure it seems to me uh and I've
never thought of of the parallel but in
in reality we have a situation where
we've now made an enormous number of
people both kids but also really adults
incredibly worried we have a Camarillo
Harris who will go out and say this is
an existential threat and we have
everyone telling us this could be the
end of mankind that is a terrible thing
to tell people now if it was true we
should probably be saying it but it's
not that's not what the U.N climate
panel is telling us and so just just as
concerned as we should be about the the
terrible state of of people being
hypochondriacs and and and living in
this permanent state of fear there's
something really odd about the fact that
we've allowed ourselves to live in a in
a society now where a large number of
people in all the top politicians are
telling us this is the end of the world
and of course it makes us make really
bad decisions yeah you know there was a
game back in a days called [__] I
think we need to start playing [__]
again I was I was we're studying why do
you know what immigrants in America make
the biggest income per year do you know
what from what country make the biggest
income per year is it not uh Korean and
Japanese it's Indians really India above
everybody it's not even close by the way
Japan's up there China's up there we
were doing a video here next week on
this topic we're doing it this week here
on this topic but then I went in there
to see why this is okay us U.S has the
Indian immigrant community in America is
only one percent American population but
eight percent of CEOs in Silicon Valley
are Indian
one percent population eight percent
okay what they're doing with stem what
percentage of their kids go to stem
versus going to regular wanting to be
teachers and all these other degrees and
then it led to this whole Rabbit Hole I
went into on pair you know Indian
parenting right go to indiaparenting.com
go to India parenting.com uh I think
this is the set I hope I get it right
maybe if I'm wrong we're just gonna have
to Google it and it'll come up uh type
Indian India parenting Indian parenting
let's see if this comes up there it is
that's the one is it India or Indian
parenting that's the one okay and why
isn't it coming up we just looked at
this two days ago it's not coming we
need an Indian I.T guy this website real
quick help us out here this website gave
10 things this website I was just on the
site two days ago this website gave 10
reasons or 10 10 things Indian parents
do that's different you know it was
point eight or number nine judgmental
and you're like wow because you
typically are raised thinking what
don't judge don't don't give them bad
self-esteem lift them upside said what
Indian parents do is they judge hardcore
and they'll judge and say that kid is
bad that that it is this is [__]
don't buy into this don't buy into that
don't buy into this I think we need to
get a little judgmental again with big
Pharma and freaking climate change I
think we need to judge a little bit and
say hey
Greta
Al Gore I'm going to pull a [__]
card on you buddy I think you're full of
[__] go ahead let's see what you got
here with your Oscar award-winning
performance that you had scaring the
crap out of all the people what kind of
liability or responsibility should you
get for doing that anyways we went in a
whole different Rabbit Hole today
phenomenal now we have to go read a
bunch of different material I was not
looking forward to having to do this but
we have to do this now and it's all
because of you yeah why'd you do that
what's this all about we're being
friendly with you yes and then I just
make you all interested in all kinds you
know what I don't appreciate it but stop
playing games my heart do appreciate is
a great conversation and we had that
today with you we're thankful for you
for coming out this was fantastic uh we
want to encourage everybody to go buy uh
our friends here's book false alarm how
climate change Panic costs us trillions
of dollars hurts to poor and fails to
fix the planet the link will be below
Rob both in chat and as well as
description uh Beyond once again and
sorry and if you are interested in the
12 smart Solutions I'm coming out with a
book this month it'll be cost uh called
best things first is that also on Amazon
to put the link it will be but no it's
not yet but all right well we're going
to get you the link so fantastic we'll
put that there as well but uh it's great
having you on thanks for coming out this
was fantastic gang we're doing a live
podcast this Thursday
uh with uh uh we're looking forward to
seeing you guys there at uh 59.90 live
Dave Rubin if not you will see it on
podcast except we're doing it Thursday
night we're not doing the warning we're
doing a Thursday night seven tonight
first time we're testing this we'll see
what's gonna happen a lot of European
people who watch the podcast will be
sleeping but I want you to wake up and
stay up there I want you to stay up
because we're going to do a bunch of
things to help minimize your hypochondri
you're dealing with all these BS
commercials that we have to watch 75 of
the time anyways man bear pig thank you
everybody bye bye-bye thank you Bjorn